est ce que c'est possible de voyager
locale avec nous marie julie gagnon
autres et ce journaliste chroniqueuse
voyage bonsoir ça alors nous sommes dans
cette période de déconfinement de
réouverture progressive
on a les soutiens du gouvernement qui se
multiplient est ce qu'on est capable de
voir un peu quelle tendance se dessine
pour les vacances d'été mais ça sera une
été on s'en doute pas comme les autres
mais effectivement il ya plusieurs
choses qui se dessine
outre le camping qui connaît un regain
de popularité sans précédent
on l'a vu entre autres avec la mise en
vente hier la fameuse carte annuelle des
éditions spéciales de la sépaq qui a
vraiment été complètement prise berson
le site internet étaient pris d'assaut
hier par les gens qui ont envie de
nature non ce besoin d'évasion mais de
se retrouver dans un cadre naturel je
pense et de respirer et dont la blessure
le camping est votre méthode une
tendance qui se démarque aussi assez
nettement pour cet été c'est celle des
longs séjours
on voit les eaux tv par exemple qui
mettent de l'avant des promotions
vraiment très variés mais qu'ils veulent
qu'ils font en sorte de nous garder un
peu plus longtemps sur place
on voit par exemple la troisième ou la
quatrième nuit gratuite
on voit des nuitées à 50% dans certains
cas aussi donc vraiment toutes sortes de
choses qui sont mises en place on a même
vu des forfaits tout compris dans des
lieux où l'on s'attendait pas du tout à
voir ce genre de promotion là parce
qu'en haute saison l'été c'est
généralement complet il ya beaucoup de
voyageurs internationaux
je pense au château frontenac qui vient
de lancer justement une promotion tout
compris dont on parle ne veut pas
activités hébergement bien sûr et
d'autres petits bonus du côté de germain
charlevoix même chose on propose la
formule tout compris pour cet été ça
vient tout juste d'être lancé donc ce
sont des initiatives qu'on n'aurait pas
vu je pense seulement une année
classique nul donc ça fait partie des
choses qui sont mises de l'avant on
risque de passer plus de temps un pour
nous c'est rassurant d'être dans un
cadre disons plus familier pendant
quelques jours d'un point de vue
sanitaire et pour les hôtels et bien
évidemment c'est pas leur avantage qu'on
change pas trop de classe puis même du
côté des chalets quand on pense aux
locations pour les cinq personnes et
plus qui doivent être absolument
laissé vacant pendant au moins 24 heures
on comprend aussi pourquoi ce genre de
probation là existe en ce moment là il
n'y a pas de voyageurs de l'extérieur
essentiellement il n'y aura pas de
touristes étrangers parce que la
frontière est fermée mais comment
s'adaptent les voyagistes qui propose
des circuits sont intéressants parce que
toutes sortes de choses qu'on a vues
naître dès le début en fait il ya
quelques semaines des jeunes et des gens
comme caravanes y qui ont mis de l'avant
des espèces de circuits qui font la
promotion justement des voyages au
québec c'est des agences qui nous avait
fait normalement le bout du monde
explorer des contrées des voyages
aventure très très très très extrêmes et
des paysages et là maintenant on nous
propose des voyages de randonnée ou de
kayak plutôt au québec on a vu aussi le
gouvernement du québec qui a lancé le
programme explore québec sur la route
dimanche dernier lors d'une conférence
de presse de la ministre du tourisme
caroline proulx donc c'est ce qui est
intéressant avec ce programme le sait
qu'on va carrément à passer par un
forfaitistes une agence réceptive pour
se procurer un forfait
donc je sois en autocar ou un autotour
donc c'est nous qui conduisons ou alors
en train et toutes sortes de choses qui
ont été concoctés par les différents
forfaitistes et donc ça me donne un
rabais de 25 % sur ses forfaits l'a donc
un programme gouvernemental
le gouvernement aussi à lancer le
programme là que le passeport attrait
donc il va nous donner aussi des rabais
sur différentes attractions de notre
région ou du reste du québec donc se
font partie des mesures de fond qui sont
mises de l'avant pour que pour
encourager le tourisme quel est
l'intérêt de tout le monde pour voyager
et nous chez le moment puisque jamais
japon nous laisser profiter du monde
pourrait que le québec même s'ils n'ont
pas de festival qu'est ce que ça change
l'absence de festivals cet été
ah ouais c'est sûr que c'est un gros
morceau il ya des gens qui voyagent pour
les festivals du côté de montréal
effectivement on peut pas de
rassemblement et en europe mais on
devine elle vise une septième
intéressante pour un peu pallier à tout
ça je pense aux festives de
baie-saint-paul dans charlevoix qui à
chaque année est un événement rempli de
surprises et tout ça n'y aura pas de
festival puisqu'ils sont interdits
pendant tout l'été partout au québec
par contre on ne concordaient des
séances d'écouté dans on vend des
billets qu'on peut se procurer en ligne
et on se rend à bessens pas dans un lieu
pittoresque ce que ce soit
chance selon l'artiste est proposée ou
la plage bref les différents endroits
comme ça on peut écouter l'artiste dans
un environnement bucolique ou carrément
ils ont décidé de concocter une petite
édition vous appréciez le tout petit
estime donc on risque d'avoir des
surprises de ce côté là aussi le pendant
l'été peut-être qu'on verra naître des
initiatives du genre aussi dans votre
région est ce que les québécois vont
bouder montréal qui a pas de festival
qu'est-ce qui reste pour les accueillir
et à montréal écoutez moi ce que j'ai
oublié par rapport à son nom il y aura
pas de festival mais je pense que c'est
le moment plus que jamais de découvrir
le montréal des montréalais et quand je
pense je pense par exemple aux
différents quartiers même le vieux port
qui est généralement pris d'assaut par
les touristes d'un peu partout on va
pouvoir peut-être se balader et le
découvrir disons plus calmement quelles
habitudes vous avec mme un peu moins de
monde autour parce que le vieux port
comme d'autres endroits tout est en
train de rouvrir
on a vu entre autres voilà voilà qui
annonce les ouvertures il va voir la
plage la plage du pied de l'horloge
aussi qui va accueillir bientôt les
visiteurs donc je pense que la façon de
visiter montréal ça va être peut-être
justement prenons plus longtemps et pour
les gens qui ont envie de voir les
musées le c'est le moment plus que
jamais de dire je viens moyal je prends
le temps de faire toutes ces visites ce
qui m'intéresse donc je peux pour qu'on
voudrait montréal même si clairement on
de vue l'instabilité qui est tous on a
vu les chiffres qui faisait pas je pense
que plus de temps à passer plus les gens
vont être confiant en quelques mots ou
est-ce qu'on peut aller ailleurs au pays
ou flac notre question j'aimerais vous
dire oui pour le moment je pense qu'on
devrait prioriser le québec pour toutes
sortes de raisons on devient ce sens
avec les îles de la madeleine pour le
corridor pour se rendre jusque jusqu'aux
îles et donc en traversant le nouveau
brunswick a pas très envie de voir
arriver des québécois alors pour le
moment je vous dirai peut-être essayer
de penser plutôt des vacances au québec
mais surveillé l'évolution ça et si une
chose à retenir de cet été c'est la
flexibilité
je pense qu'on va falloir s'adapter au
fur et à mesure selon les situations
comment ils vont évoluer je pense c'est
le seul conseil qu'on peut le donner et
ne prenez pas pour acquis que c'est
complet partout beaucoup d'annulations
c'est le temps de prendre le téléphone
qui te voir justement ici au bon endroit
aucun on rêve depuis longtemps qu'ils
auraient soudaine
ce que je dis barre parce que des gens
oui j'ai ma bulle et en europe et
quelque part
alors c'est intéressant parce qu'on vous
écoute puis on comprend bien qu'il y
aura un été touristique possible marie
julie gagnon merci beaucoup pressé